hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
canadá en las américas café el programa
semanal del servicio en español de radio
canadá internacional hoy estamos aquí en
el estudio con ustedes leonora chapman
que tal yo no ahora
ahí está micrófono pablo gómez barrio sí
señor
leo no lo he menos y leonardo jiménez
luis laborda hoy damos la bienvenida a
todos los que nos siguen a través del
facebook live y también porque no todos
quienes nos siguen a través de youtube
así es que nos pueden seguir ahora en
vivo también no solamente a través de
facebook lite sino a través de la
plataforma de youtube y también nos
pueden seguir desde la página de
internet de radio canal internacional
barra oblicua s es decir español porque
en la parte en la página principal se
desplaza el carrusel de la de las
entrevistas hacia abajo y ustedes pueden
hacer clic a donde dice ahí un pequeño
link
un pequeño vínculo para abrir la emisión
que reproduce lo que está saliendo nieto
efectivamente recuerden que a partir de
hoy mismo poco después del mediodía hora
de aquí de montreal ustedes pueden
observar nuestra emisión en nuestro
sitio en internet como lo acaba de decir
leonardo www.bcn.cat estamos ajustando
los últimos detalles técnicos para
dentro de poco puedo darles una
para que nos puedan seguir a través de
una página específica de youtube pero
mientras tanto a quienes nos quieran
seguir a través de youtube pueden hacer
simplemente una búsqueda allí poniendo
el nombre de la emisión canal en las
américas de café y aparecen todos los
programas que estamos llevando a cabo
desde hace ya algunas semanas en esa
novedosa plataforma así que entonces
tienen youtube facebook live y el sitio
en internet del radio canadá para seguir
en directo este programa que permanece
ahora en línea viernes sábado y domingo
exacto entonces yo ya no sé si decir que
este es el programa del 4 de febrero
es el programa de la primera semana de
febrero es la primera semana que no tuve
las cuentas pero bueno ahí tienen
entonces distintas plataformas para
seguirnos más vías de comunicación
para poder comunicarse con nosotros
ustedes recuerden que siempre tienen la
posibilidad de dejarnos mensajes ya sea
en nuestro sitio en internet o enviarnos
también sus opiniones a través de el
correo electrónico estamos siempre en
espera de su participación para poder
saber cuáles son los temas que les
interesan cuáles son sus inquietudes y
estamos siempre receptivos a cualquier
sugerencia que ustedes quieran hacernos
[Música]
y más
bueno muy bien y para no estamos ya con
el programa propiamente dicho cuáles son
los temas que le han llamado la atención
en esta semana pues son los temas de
esos insólitos fuera de lo común que les
han llamado la atención si es que ha
habido alguno vos tenías yo tengo pero
ustedes yo tengo uno no es insólito sino
que me pareció más que todo curioso y es
una noticia que publicamos hoy
justamente y es que el primer ministro
de todos dice que no regresará a la
residencia oficial del primer ministro
yo no yo pensaba que él estaba viviendo
en la residencia oficial que es el 24
sus xdrive en ottawa y resulta de que no
que no está viviendo ahí está viviendo
está viviendo ahora en ruido cottage
y lo que sucede es que
mal estado está en muy mal estado dicen
que en un informe que había hecho el
verificador general en 2008 fíjate lleva
más de ocho años 910 casi el verificador
decía que esa mansión de piedra que fue
construida en 1868 de 35 piezas tenía
unas ventanas en mal estado la tubería
del sistema eléctrico la calefacción la
climatización estaba deteriorada el
sistema no había sistema de aspersores
de agua en caso de incendio que tenemos
en todos los lugares públicos una estaba
llena de rato justicia porque dije mal
malísimamente mal y bueno pues entonces
me sorprendió un poquito y no porque yo
pensaba de que una casa o sea la casa
oficial de los primeros ministros de
canadá pues en principio debería estar
en buen estado no está todos los
primeros ministros que están entrando en
función pues deberían poder vivir ahí
pero se hace memoria cuando asumió todo
precisamente se habló de que no iba a ir
a vivir esa casa precisamente por el mal
estado en él
la misma y en aquel momento se dio una
cifra de cuál sería el costo de
reparación que ahora nos recuerda
embriones diez millones 10 millones
bueno lo interesante también es que
justamente la ciencia declaración en una
entrevista que le dio a la red si vice a
la radio inglesa de radio canadá y él
decía que no que no cree que vaya a
vivir durante su mandato como primer
ministro la residencia oficial pero
decían los portavoces de los partidos
conservadores y del otro del partido
conservador y del mpd decía que de todas
formas ellos no se van a oponer a oponer
si el primer ministro ordena que se
hagan las renovaciones que se le tienen
que hacer a esa manchado porque cuando
en su momento se despertó llevar a cabo
esas reparaciones hubo voces que dijeron
que se trata de un edificio que tiene un
valor histórico muy importante y que es
de hecho patrimonio de canadá y que
entonces hay una cierta especie de
obligación de mantener ese edificio en
condición pero si me acuerdo este es un
problema que viene desde hace muchísimo
tiempo vos hablaste de trudeau
de antes de que se fue acumulando el
problema y recuerdo que el ex primer
ministro conservador mal ron y cuando él
ingresó a esa residencia gastó 300 mil
dólares de su bolsillo para acondicionar
cosas urgentes que había y cuando
terminó su mandato eso lo contaba él
cuando terminó su mandato quiso llevarse
las cosas que lo acusaban de ladrón de
haber malgastado
eso del piano lo sé pero en todo caso
los primeros ministros parece que eran
un poco reacios a gastar en esa casa
porque inmediatamente llovían las
críticas como diciendo era malgastar el
dinero que no hacía falta que uno cree
que lo hacen para por cuestión de qué sé
yo de vivir en un ambiente de ricos
antes de precisamente totales para
evitar ese tipo de acusaciones cuando
asumió el actual la actual
administración es recuerdo que hubo
muchísimos que dijeron
aunque el anterior pero el ministro no
hizo poner ni un tornillo en esa casa
tal vez lo que harper está previendo es
que alguien no fuera real bueno ahora
todos los partidos están de acuerdo en
que efectivamente hay que invertir y hay
que hacer algo por esa casa que se está
cayendo en pedazos pero seguro que
alguna queja alguna
bueno a lo mejor hayan quejas no pero ya
por lo menos los códigos políticos en el
parlamento de ottawa están hay un
consenso para que se se hagan las
renovaciones necesarias es un edificio
que se puede visitar de hecho cuando se
lleva a cabo creo que en el mes de mayo
la semana de puertas abiertas en la
ciudad de ottawa donde se pueden visitar
los distintos lugares y edificios
públicos etcétera
esa residencia es una de las que ofrece
puertas abiertas y se puede visitar debe
ser interesante ir a ver entonces ir a
constatar el deterioro que se encuentra
algún otro tema se fue me encontré
interesante algo no puede ser algo
insólito pero bueno ese que la habla una
pareja de patinadores artísticos de
corea del norte que está participando en
las olimpiadas que empiezan ahora y que
se llevan a cabo en corea del sur están
entrenados por un entrenador de quebec
entonces me pareció que algo para
destacar no es el mismo que había
entrenado también un equipo de frank
dario es sí entonces es un entrenador
bastante conocido que ya hizo campeones
del mundo y es lo que me llamó la
atención es ver que corea del norte
mandado a esta pareja a entrenarse aquí
en que yo escuché algo todavía más
insólito en duración a estos juegos
políticos
esta mañana escuchando la radio antes
venir para calles que ya se ha batido un
récord antes como la comunidad de áfrica
una africana que hace participa en esquí
africana que participa en juegos de
invierno en línea y representando que no
sé no esto es un récord que ya se ya se
batió cuando todo yo creo que faltan
exactamente cuántos días pero la
competencia no empezó aún y ya hay un
récord que ha sido batido
de la venta de tickets no estuviste
cerca se trata de bueno sin
necesariamente de venta pero de entrega
de algo la entrega de las entradas
gratuitas el reparto de preservativos
pero si no van allá para eso van a
competir parece que compiten claro pero
en realidad me parece que ese deporte de
verano no sé realmente pero he escuchado
la información esta mañana y de
información dice que ya se ha batido el
récord en la cantidad de preservativo
que se han distribuido antes de que
empiece para los de verano del año
pasado se había el tema cuando que había
hecho una nota sobre una aplicación que
salió una especie de kinder que es una
aplicación de citas que se usa
explícitamente para conseguir pareja de
una noche en este caso habían hecho una
aplicación específica para todos los
competidores de los juegos olímpicos y
que ellos podían bloquearse y ver
quiénes estaban de otros equipos
olímpicos de otros países dispuestos a
pasar una buena noche aunque todavía no
hemos tenido noticias de una nueva
aplicación para piernas pero supongo que
en algún momento de abrazar y lo que
sucede es que utilizan esos
preservativos para hacer globos y los
regalan pero de a cinco con los cinco
anillos
e imaginación y yo le quería comentar
muy rápidamente también el tema de este
astrónomo amateur canadiense un hombre
que vive en columbia británica scott
kelly de 47 años de edad que es un
astrónomo aficionado y que realizando
las mediciones que lleva a cabo
periódicamente en sus ratos de ocio él
dice que incluso quitándole tiempo a su
propia familia usando equipos de señales
de radio y cámaras de televisión que
tiene instaladas en el techo de sus
viviendas
este dichoso señor en su en su en su
pasatiempo encontró nada más y nada
menos que un satélite que había sido
extraviado por la nasa en el año 2050 le
conoce para saber qué es un satélite
extraviado debe tener cierto
conocimiento usando usando los equipos
de detección de ondas de radio el
detectó una señal que le pareció extraña
que no cuajaba con las señales que
estaba acostumbrado a recibir
periódicamente
aquí el huevo raro empezó a analizar la
información empezó a buscar más
información y mediciones más precisas y
llegó a identificar con precisión que se
trata del satélite que había extraviado
la nasa en el 2005 es decir hace ya 12
años y desde el extravío de ezeiza tití
llegó incluso a que en el año 2007 la
nasa cancelar la misión así que ahora
habiendo encontrado el cero puede quedar
porque estaba pensando que por lo menos
la nasa debería pensar en darle una
buena presente telescopio no bajen que
se lo pongan en la casa y es interesante
el hecho porque no sé si ustedes saben
que aquí en quebec mismo hoy en en todo
canadá existen muchísimos clubes de
aficionados a la astronomía yo tengo un
telescopio en mi casa con el cuándo
observación a la luna roja no sabéis
grave pero sin telescopio y estaba en el
autobús viniendo para aquí ese día y es
noticias como estas entonces puede
llevar al entrar a esta agencia que siga
con su constancia o algo en su
pasatiempo en toda esta cantidad inmensa
de clubes de astrónomos aficionados que
hay inclusive muy cerquita de aquí que
periódicamente se reúne en distintos
puntos de preservación de la provincia
para a mirar estrellas los planetas
nebulosas etcétera etcétera o sea hay
lugares muy especiales en quebec para
mirar el cielo si el aire en la crean
tica y es casi casi de cero polución
lumínica sí y hay un observatorio que
dicen que es realmente precioso y yo
sobre la ocasión de ir en un verano y
ellos hacen incluso hay un lugar para
acampar en el parque y tú vas a acampar
en ese parque y por las noches hay
actividades en las que puede decir
y todos dan conferencias y todos los
maestros es bien interesante si invitan
también hacer observaciones en invierno
las estrellas ya es demasiado
hoy comentábamos pablo con voz
particularmente pero un tema de
conversación de todos de los cambios que
se están por introducir en la versión en
inglés del himno nacional y el himno
hace cambios que han sido aprobados por
el parlamento y que tiene que refrendar
el gobernador general para que en la
protección a ex astronauta julie payette
exactamente esos cambios vienen
motivados en este caso en particular por
una expresión que figuraba en la letra
en inglés que se tildó de sexista porque
se habla de hijos de canadá y entonces
la palabra hijos implica que el género
masculino y se va a cambiar entonces por
una expresión que sigue siendo se exige
el español pero no es no es en inglés
que es todos nosotros
incluidos ellos efectiva hicieron una
comisión para cambiar esta propuesta
hubo muchos proyectos para cambiar la
letra de conmigo y yo tengo que hubo 12
desde el año 1984 vigencia del himno
pero que ninguno de ellos luego será
aprobado a excepción de este último pero
ahora este último fue una emoción muy
concreta presentada por un diputado del
partido liberal que cree que murió
justamente ahora antes de que esto se
aprobara que él decía que era injusto
que haya un reconozca y se deje de lado
al 52% de la población a no ser en la
creación de este país y el desarrollo de
este país y lo interesante del tema es
que la mayor oposición la oposición
venía del lado de la la de los
conservadores en el parlamento que a
toda costa además querían impedir que se
cambiara esa letra del himno nacional a
este primero de julio pasado donde se
celebraban los 150 años de canadá en el
2017 querían que se mantuviera
exactamente el mismo el colegio no tal
cual estaba
y ahora en el parlamento fue como vos
dijiste pues la moción fue aprobada
crudo el primer ministro también está
totalmente de acuerdo y pues ahora va a
poner y es un cambio que se hace sólo en
inglés porque en francés no hace falta y
es un solo cambio porque pablo nos puede
contar yo digo utilizado durante una
sugerencia de que dijo más o sea ese
sobre todo en la versión francesa de
del himno bueno todos sabemos que canadá
es un país de inmigración ha habido
mucha inmigración desde siempre para
poblar este país y en el himno nacional
habla dice o canadá ter de messager
quiere decir tierra de mis ancestros
ante paséis mis antepasados entonces no
aquí en esta mesa por ejemplo ninguno de
nuestros antepasados es canadienses y
somos y somos acá nadie es bosque sabes
a lo mejor un tatarabuelo tuyo anduvo
por acá vos decís no pero creo que
hablan justamente de la de los
autóctonos y eso pero los dos son los
empezamos son las primeras naciones
naciones sobre todo las habría que poner
un barra inmigrante por ejemplo
eso demuestra que no es el único cambio
posible en el himno y en todo caso es un
cambio que se puede efectivizarse pablo
gómez barrios
voy a tener que hablar con la
gobernadora general pues muy bien
aquí les habla marco castillo productor
músico brasileño que vive en winnipeg y
los invito a escuchar canadá en las
américas café de la radio canadá
internacional en la web bueno yo
particularmente siempre hablo de los
mensajes de los docentes y después estos
muy poco tiempo así que podemos empezar
a dar de ese espacio de esos mensajes y
pablo tiene uno que nos llega a través
de facebook si nos está nos envía un
saludo
nelson contreras rincón desde más rank y
allá él dice buenas tardes saludos desde
barranquilla colombia
vivís sanz nos manda muchos aplausos y
javier gonzález nungaray ahora le tocó a
luis laborda coordinar la mesa muchos
saludos a todos estoy al pendiente bueno
si usted sabe que la coordinación es
rotativa y frecuentemente caso también
reemplazos así que más de una vez nos ha
tocado a unos oa otros
en días no previstos inclusive pero
también tenemos mensajes escritos
algunos
a un mensaje de rodrigo vega y él
escribe sobre salvadoreños en la mira de
trump que podrían buscar residencia en
canal y empieza diciendo las
inmigraciones selectivas y controladas
siempre han existido en diversas épocas
y en distintos países incluso algunos
países o uniones de países han elaborado
sus legislaciones migratorias basados en
los planes económicos internos y en las
necesidades económicas específicas de
esos países bueno él se refiere a chile
argentina uruguay que también han
acogido una inmigración selectiva dice
él y se hace una pregunta dice porque se
ha armado tanto escándalo por el hecho
de que el presidente trump quiera hacer
una inmigración selectiva y controlada
en su país o es que el presidente troupe
no tiene derecho a hablar y a decidir
sobre las políticas migratorias de su
gobierno
no no no por carla yo estoy leyendo un
libro
que cuenta la historia de unos
inmigrantes griegos que llegaron a eeuu
en los años veinte y en la isla de ellis
era exactamente lo mismo no sé más esto
ni siquiera había manera de saber que
uno iba a ser rechazado no llegaba le
decían afuera directamente o sea siempre
hubo una política está bien entonces no
es nuevo lo que pasa es que este hombre
muchas veces atenta con contra otros
valores eso lo que provoca la reticencia
de la gente con respecto si vemos las
expresiones que tuvo con países
africanos y vemos las primeras
expresiones donde asumió con los
mexicanos entonces provoca un todo lo
que él dice pues provoca un rechazo
inmediato además yo creo que las
mayorías críticas y reticencias las que
se refería a leonardo no están dirigidas
específicamente al hecho de que tenga la
potestad o no que la tiene evidentemente
de imponer una política inmigratoria
sino el hecho de que quiere expeler del
territorio estadounidense un montón de
gente que hace en algunos casos de
carácter de generación tiene su vida
decir bien 10
y el caso de un mexicano si mal no
recuerdo que había nacido en méxico pero
con muy pocos meses de vida fue llevado
por sus padres a estados unidos creció
en eeuu se educó en eeuu comenzó a
trabajar en eeuu tiene toda su familia
en eeuu y dinero y regresó a méxico a
donde llegó no conoce a nadie no conoce
ni siquiera la lengua porque no le
inculca no le enseñaron el español sus
padres ni siquiera conoce el idioma
entonces llega un país distinto que
supuestamente es el de él pero no le
pertenece al que no conoce de ninguna
manera no tiene la lengua para eso más
que nada por ahí pasaría la posibilidad
de crítica no es cierto y por algún
mensaje escrito de nuestros oyentes si
el tema es juez bloquea decisión de
trump de poner final de poner fin al
programa daca para inmigrantes javier
gonzález nungaray justamente él dice
otro revés para trump de momento yo
desconozco a fondo la legislación con
respecto a este tema anda acá pero ya
están ganando terreno los afectados
los dreamers de momento seguramente el
señor trump ya está haciendo su
berrinche saludos cordiales a ruffo
valencia y nos escribía javier gonzález
nungaray y yo aquí tengo un mensaje pero
en este caso con respecto a la
inmigración de canadá y el refugio en
canadá dice refugiados en canadá si está
viendo asilo si es refugiado o si lo fue
cuéntenos su historia en este caso joan
estrada en dice olas buenas tardes mi
nombre es iván estrada soy de venezuela
por la situación grave que está pasando
mi país tuve que salir con mi familia
para colombia que mi esposo es de allá
pero nos va a peor
porque a mi esposo no consigue trabajo y
no tenemos dónde vivir tengo tres niños
la mayor nueve seis y diez meses y me
preocupa el futuro de mis hijos y su
opción gracias ojalá y con el favor de
dios nos ayuda en este caso bueno le
contamos a joan estrada que puede ir a
los sitios de inmigración canadá para
ver la posibilidad de refugio en este
país bueno yo de leer un mensaje muy
cortito antes de comenzar a presentar
nuestros temas para los oyentes y es
sobre el tema canadá y su plan de
migración 2018 no se escribe y ahí se
está ahora más
malagrida y dice somos un matrimonio
estable y tenemos dos hijos de 6 y 7
años deseamos obtener una visa para
trabajar en canadá que debemos hacer y
como lo hemos dicho en muchísimas otras
veces
también están los formularios en español
se puede encontrar así que es muy fácil
si igual ósea
aclaremos que nada está receptivo a
recibir gente o sea está todo preparado
para eso la gente que tenga intención
ir a esos sitios a buscar la información
necesaria bueno muy bien vamos entonces
a presentarles las sugerencias de temas
a nuestros oyentes temas en los que
hemos estado trabajando a lo largo de
los últimos días quién de ustedes quiere
comenzar nadie yo estoy buscando para ir
mostrando los temas mientras bueno
entonces empiezo yo les sugiero o les
sea acerca de mi parte una entrevista
que se días pasados con un sindicalista
mexicano benedicto martínez quien estuvo
presente la semana aquí en montreal
participando de un encuentro que se
organizó en la universidad de quebec en
montreal uqam a raíz del tratado de
libre comercio de américa del norte como
ustedes saben se encuentra en pleno
proceso de renegociación a partir de
iniciativa precisamente del presidente
estadounidense de querer reformular el
contenido de ese acuerdo para evitar lo
que él sostiene que son abusos que
realizan tanto canadá como méjico en
materia de comercio internacional
gracias a ese instrumento y este
sindicalista que pertenece a una de las
federaciones más importantes de méxico
que estuvo aquí dando el punto de vista
a la opinión de los trabajadores
mexicanos él sostuvo entre otras cosas
que este tratado es un tratado que sólo
ha beneficiado a los gobiernos como
tales y a las empresas multinacionales
pero que ha habido siempre a lo largo de
toda la discusión desde que se lo
implementó hasta hoy en día un gran
ausente que es precisamente la clase
trabajadora y que al contrario lo que
dice el presidente estaounidense el
tratado de libre comercio para américa
del norte no ha beneficiado en ningún
aspecto a los trabajadores mexicanos
sino por el contrario ha favorecido la
implementación de políticas que ya se
han conocido en muchos otros lugares y
que los argentinos que estamos aquí
conocemos muy bien qué es la
flexibilización laboral que son todos
ustedes que han llevado ese señor aquí
ha llevado a bajar los salarios
a anular oa romper o a deshacer en más
de una ocasión los convenios laborales
que son los que rigen la estructura del
trabajo en cada uno de esos países y que
entonces no hay razón alguna para
sostener que el lado de los trabajadores
mexicanos al menos se ha producido
ningún tipo de abuso si es que ha habido
algún abuso ha sido en todo caso de
empresas que son las que siempre se
benefician con este tipo de instrumentos
según dice benedicto martínez y que
según él entiende el tratado de libre
comercio para américa del norte al cual
existe hoy en día no tiene razón alguna
para ser preservado es decir a él ya sus
representantes no les daría ninguna pena
deshacerse de este tratado se habla
mucho de las subvenciones que se otorgan
a empresas y entre las subvenciones o
sea el mercado todo lo que el sector
agrícola estadounidense
es subvencionado ampliamente por por el
estado y ha afectado de una forma
directa a todo el sector agrícola
mexicano donde por ejemplo artículos de
primera necesidad como el maíz y como
los frijoles
amén ahora en este mismo momento están
casi los cultivadores mexicanos
perdiendo porque entra todo el maíz
subvencionado y los frijoles
subvencionados de eeuu hacia méxico y
pues esa gente prácticamente ya no no no
está no está sobreviviendo como lo hacía
antes entonces son elementos que donald
trump no tiene en cuenta en en el
balance que él hace sobre el tele cambio
y eso es en parte verdad pero no es toda
la verdad según declaraciones y una
entrevista que dio obrador a un
periodista de civis y estuve leyendo
donde reconocía que también había sido
beneficioso el tlcan para méxico en
muchos sectores entonces habría como que
poner un poco la balanza también porque
si se ha beneficiado en méxico también
con el tlcan pero también se ha
perjudicado dependiendo de los sectores
y yo voy a hablar de bombas asesinas que
me parece un tema muy interesante
se trata de esto ocurrió durante la
segunda guerra mundial asesinas de
barcos le decían desde apodo y fueron
creadas por los alemanes los nazis que
eran bombas en ese momento era algo
novedoso en tiradas lanzadas desde
aviones dirigidas específicamente a
barcos y estaban dirigidas es un poco lo
serán los las antecesoras de lo que hoy
se conoce los drones los drones por
ejemplo más inteligentes bombas
inteligentes lo que dicen bombas
planeadoras denuncian también y que las
llamaba justamente asesinas de barcos
eran lanzadas a gran altura en todo lo
que lo que impedía que por ejemplo los
cañones antiaéreos de los barcos
lograran alcanzarlas y eran controladas
remotamente a través de señales de radio
entonces en ese momento que se
desarrollaba esa tecnología por parte de
los alemanes y los aliados empezaron un
poco a cuestionarse a desesperarse por
si avanzaba y esta fue la idea de dos
canadienses que encontraron una solución
para ese problema y en un tiempo
récord en un mes se trata de w wilkinson
que es un físico y un ingeniero de sólo
26 años graduado de la queen's
universidad hay de de ontario y que
ellos tuvieron la tarea está pues
crucial se consideró en su momento de
detener esas bombas de planeadoras que
se había antecedentes de esto lo que
estaba dos bombas serán suficientes para
liquidar un barco de los aliados con más
de 203 personas como tripulantes y este
dúo entonces se recurrió al campo de la
física de la de la interferencia de
radio que era un un campo relativamente
nuevo como lo hicieron pues hay que ver
qué es lo que inventa lo que sí puedo
adelantar porque es interesante que
vayan y lean también este artículo como
lo hicieron es que después que estos
canadienses inventaron encontraron la
manera de detener a estas bombas en la
tasa de éxito de estas bombas que se
estaban en un calculadas en un 30 por
ciento es decir tres barcos de cada diez
eran
cansados en un menos de un año pasó a 0%
gracias a este invento de los
canadienses que después fueron mejorados
estas tecnologías por los británicos los
estadounidenses y pues hoy tenemos estos
drones que ya son directamente ya no son
bombas sino aviones con pues toda la
integral de esta nueva tecnología no
sólo podemos decir que ellos en parte
torcieron entonces también la marcha de
absolutamente tuvieron una gran
influencia en el resultado de la segunda
guerra mundial y que son en otro
hablantes de normandía de la de bargemon
desde el desembarco al barco el famoso
desembarco pero fue brillante la
solución que encontraron entonces me
interese muchísimo en esa historia por
eso perfecto muy bien pablo si antes de
comenzar con lo mío quería agregar
regresando a lo del tlcan que esta
semana el ex primer ministro canadiense
conservador brian mulroney se encontraba
en washington de van delante de una
comisión senatorial defendiendo
justamente el tratado del libre comercio
bueno fue una defensa muy estudiada
y concluía finalmente lo que manuel
lópez obrador decía en el comentario
conciencia dice que finalmente salvo
raras excepciones el tratado de libre
comercio de américa del norte ha creado
riqueza y ganancias para los tres países
ese era el comentario del señor brian
mulroney y bien y yo les quiero los
quiero invitar a escuchar una entrevista
muy simpática que dice con una mexicana
justamente que hace 10 años que está
viviendo aquí en canadá
ella era profesora de español en
guanajuato méxico y perdón
escribió a los cuatro libros para
enseñar justamente el español y bueno
llegó acá a canadá y empezó a se fue
hacia la costa norte fue al norte de la
provincia de québec su marido es de esa
región y trabajaba ya entonces se fue
para allá ya ya comenzó a enseñar
español y le tocó pues también que
aprender el francés porque no hablaba
francés cuando llegó entonces ella me
decía en la entrevista que se había
aplicado a ella misma para el francés el
mismo método que ella aplicaba para
enseñarle el español a sus estudiantes y
me decía pues que en una semana ya
alcanzaba a tener una conversación y a
desenvolverse en una semana en una
semana
entonces voy a desenvolverse me imagino
que es muy aplicada ella es tan aplicada
que cuando aprendió el francés se
inscribió en la academia de hotelería de
echar lengua y es aquí el punto ella
estudió en la academia de hotelería de
la lengua restauración y
biglieri a de tal suerte que hoy en día
es una sumiller acreditada por la
asociación de sumilleres de canadá y
cazadora de vino eso es una muy
particular catadora de vino especialista
en vinos sudamericanos entre otros
conoce todos los otros vinos pero
también en vinos sudamericanos nos
hablaba de la producción vinícola de
méxico que es naciente de alguna forma y
que no es comparable por ejemplo a
países como argentina y chile que tiene
una tradición bastante antigua bastante
vieja en la elaboración del vino
entonces pues fue una conversación muy
simpática y yo los invito a escuchar a
los que les gusta el vino ya los que no
les gusta también para que escuchen sus
comentarios sobre la cata de vino he
hecho una mixtura entre sus dos pasiones
digamos que comenzar con cursos de
español en los que entre entre
conversación y conversación se puede
agregar una
el vino no se olvida
[Música]
de la lengua la lengua eso parecería de
verdad un momento teatral en todo caso
vamos a ver si es posible que la
invitemos acá a este estudio para que
venga y nos hable de los vinos y ella
pese podría hacernos una demostración
práctica aquí a partir de entrevistas
donde enteré de la existencia de la
palabra sumillier porque realmente todo
mi vida escuché hablar de él en
argentina decimos 120 euros y yo suelo
sabes cómo son en argentina y francés
pero nunca he escuchado la palabra
asumiría y efectivamente con pablo la
buscamos hoy en internet en el
diccionario de la real academia y existe
y la descripción exactamente de esta
profesión que se aplica la palabra se
aplica tanto en femenino como masculino
sumiller
es para hombres y para mujeres no tiene
género cultural pero pero el plural es
sumilleres y existe perfecto muy bien
leonardo gimeno sí bueno nosotros
hablamos de un nuevo algoritmo de
computadoras que fue aprobado en eeuu
por ésta
está
[Música]
esta entidad de los eeuu que son los que
aprueban es la idea que son los
medicamentos y todas las cosas que se
comercializan
exacto bueno en este caso es la primera
vez que ocurre que se patentó y fue
aprobada por la fd a un algoritmo para
uso en hospitales y este algoritmo es un
algoritmo que predice el amor si en
realidad tiene que ver con una cuestión
muy particular y es a la gente que está
con riesgo cardíaco riesgo
cardiovascular respiratoria salario se
le ponen ciertos monitores y este
algoritmo lo que hace es ir a la base de
datos y realizar cita miles y miles y
miles de edad si es y los que los bases
que ya los entraron esos datos o sea que
está en funcionamiento entonces estos
datos dan una posibilidad de saber hasta
con entre 6 y 8 horas de anticipación
cuando una persona va a tener
hábitat que que puede llegar a ser
mortal también lo que pasa es que uno
los médicos también lo pueden decir sin
necesidad de un aparato o un algoritmo
de estas características lo que pasa es
que en no llegan con tanta antelación y
llegar con tanta antelación tiene la
bondad predicción exacto de poder
prevenir y de empezar mucho antes
a darle los medicamentos necesarios para
que esta persona bueno exactamente no
muera y es algo realmente novedoso
porque se está investigando hace rato
pero nunca se pudo
llegar a saber con precisión exactamente
y ahora a través de este algoritmo que
apaga va a ser aprobado en eeuu uno
puede determinar que esa persona puede
tener un ataque que puede ser mortal o
sea que el tiempo de antelación es de
previsiones de 6 a 7 horas de 6 a 8
horas esto es porque lo que hacen es por
poner sensores en distintos porque la
respiración es frecuencia cardíaca la
presión y hay un montón de información
que se entrecruza que cuando empieza a
subir la temperatura para bajar un
poquito la presión y con otros datos
entonces eso da tienen una puntuación
del 0 hasta el 5 cuando es del 3 hacia
arriba hay que hacer una intervención
inmediata para salvar la vida igual esto
es en caso de gente que está ya con una
enfermedad cardiovascular grave pero no
sería de extrañar que
en el desarrollo del proceso del
desarrollo de este algoritmo en algún
momento se pueda predecir con plazos
mucho más extensos y con gente que no
esté
internada yo no me prestaría un ensayo
se prestaría un 40 por ciento de la
muestra murió y me gustaría saber cuándo
cuándo va a morir yo recuerdo que en
alguna vez hizo un sondeo entre unas
personas y muchas personas dijeron que
sí seguro porque saben que eso no existe
todo si a mí no me gustaría saber cuándo
voy a morir pero si a ver si esta tarde
me va el corazón sería interesante
a esta hora para el aeropuerto
para morirme para morirme ahogado
buenos días mi nombre es traviesa libia
director musical del conjunto proyecto
altiplano y los invito a escuchar canadá
en las américas café de radio canadá
internacional bueno muy bien tenemos ya
una vez presentado nuestros temas más
mensajes de nuestros hoy entendemos un
mensaje acá de alguien que está
siguiendo nos en directo se trata de
gustavo lucas él dice saludos desde melo
cerro largo
uruguay
por s saluditos retribuimos algunos de
los mensajes escritos que han llegado
alguno cortito tiene una mano si no
tengo uno pequeño aquí que dice sobre
que le prohíbe el niqab en los servicios
públicos
esa ley incluirá a los policías y
militares que se cubren la cara y son
funcionarios públicos pregunta pablo
también halloween será prohibido porque
la gente se cubre la cara si no es así
es persecución religiosa y civil esa es
la opinión de pablo muy bien acá tengo
también uno muy corto con respecto a
pacientes con cáncer de pulmón comienza
un tratamiento experimental en canadá
areiza nos dice un cordial saludo
tengo una pariente que sufre de cáncer
de pulmón y nos gustaría conocer más al
respecto de ese tratamiento
por favor comuníquense a este correo no
sé de dónde quién hizo que la persona
que escribe de ser cubana o no parece
bueno ya le haré y no sé a lo mejor
quiere decir que las cubanas tienen
problemas nombres así extraños
llegaban los correos escritos y llegaban
muchísima correspondencia de cubas
que es la policía montada de canadá abre
sus puertas a los inmigrantes escribe
carlos y dice soy ingeniero mexicano
pertenece al ejército mexicano dice me
gusta mucho la carrera de policía y
quisiera trabajar en su país muchísimas
gracias carlos bueno contrariamente lo
que yo pensaba que nos iba a sobrar el
tiempo nos falta como siempre tenía
otros temas de los que se podía hablar
también pero ya no tenemos más tiempo le
damos a todos muchísimas gracias por
haber estado una vez más
aquí con nosotros en canadá en las
américas café saludamos a todos quienes
nos siguen a través del facebook live y
de youtube y de todas las plataformas
que estamos integrando poco a poco y
vamos a cerrar como es costumbre con
música en este caso un artista que a mí
me gusta que programe no hace tantas
emisiones atrás
vov y sant marí y un tema que le
pertenece que le llama estar walker que
podríamos traducir como algo así como
viajero estelar chau hasta la próxima
nacional